let me pull up this tweet this is an
awesome tweet this is from clay Travis
He says lots of athletes are finally
catching on that left-wing Sports media
ask them political questions so the
left-wing Sports media members can write
their own left-wing political opinions
here's Azarenka calling that out I don't
know if we can play like if it's it's a
it's a longer video you guys want us to
do here we go listen about it like talk
about it I I don't I don't know what's
what's the goal here
that is continuously brought up and this
incident that in my opinion have nothing
to do with players
but somehow you keep dragging players
into it
so
what's the goal here
I think you should ask yourself that
question not me
sorry just a clip on that though does it
frustrate you that
um you know particularly last night for
example it was a clear sort of
pro-russian demonstration happening
within the grounds of the tournament
that these people are coming and using
the Australian Open as a platform for
these kind of demonstrations
does that frustrate you
[Music]
oh
I
know whatever the answer I'm gonna give
it to you right now it's going to be
turned whichever way you want to turn it
to
so
does it bother me what bothers me is
um
There's real things that's going on in
the world
and I don't know are you a politician
are you are you covering politics
yes and I'm a sports and I'm an athlete
and you should pause real quick I'm a
sports journalist he goes yes I'm an
athlete asking me about things that
maybe somebody says are in my control
but I don't believe that
so I don't know what you want me to
answer so anyway here's here's what I
love about this for one obviously these
athletes are alike okay at this point
what are you asking about we had that
with um what's the name Ivan provorov
the the hockey Flyers Flyers who is just
like look I'll answer any question about
sports and then someone asks them about
like gay rights and he's like what did I
just say so here's the thing
dead internet Theory we're talking about
Twitter being dead engagement is way
down for whatever reason and I don't
mean dead isn't the platform's broken I
just mean like no one seems to be using
it now we've got dead internet Theory
the idea that since like 2016 no one's
really used the internet and now you
have stories like this what you what you
see from this
Sports journalists have literally
nothing to write about so they go to uh
you know what would you say Malcolm your
your principal career is like what's
your what's your what's your main career
clinical research so um I'm I'm curious
uh when when cooking eggs in the morning
do you agree with Chef Andrew gruel on
adding vinegar afterwards and mixing it
in
um are there peer-reviewed studies I
don't know what this question has to do
with anything other than I can then go
out and be like you know clinical
researcher says no vinegar on eggs and
it makes it sound like there's a
scientific basis it makes a fake story
and then they can go I gotta scoop a guy
said a thing that's what the media is
today for the most part
oh man that is that's scary people
because people still take it seriously
that's the problem is that you know you
were just saying it you know
are people online like that do people
see this happening and you know in real
life people still take journalists
seriously that's what it really freaks
me out because you know they're getting
their information from these people who
are basically like scraping the bottom
of the barrel and sitting up anybody got
scoop who's got the scoop who's got and
they literally write nonsense to which
people export to the real world yeah and
this is what I always said was that you
know back in the day they always said
Twitter's not real life I'm like yeah
it's not real life because it's got real
life implications like people literally
use Twitter to Source what they're going
to take out to the other people and talk
about around the water cooler or you
know to write articles about well and
like for this it's it like first off
that athletes belarusi and I just looked
it up so are they trying to trap her
into being representative yeah yeah and
then also for this journalist like I'm
so glad she's like are you a politician
she's like I'm a sports journalist like
is this Sports journalist like here's my
chance to get launched into the
political on the political beat so I get
more money or I can raise my profile
because I had this good moment like it's
just such a weird way to operate and
especially since I know there are people
who would love to cover Sports
journalism at this level to go to the
Australian Open and interview these
people because they love the sport not
because they are trying to make some
political point to further their career
like if you're gonna further career on
Sports journalism ask her about
preparing for this match ask her about
something relevant don't make her a
poster child so you can sort of
transition into the political beat for
your publication
I feel like the whole like writing down
what the guy said is kind of like 1994
journalism style like you can just watch
the video of what she said I don't need
to hear someone write a story about what
she said when I can listen to her say it
or I don't need to hear someone write
down she hit the she hit the ball three
feet farther than the other girl who hit
the ball I'm like I can watch the show I
don't need that anymore I've internet
video I can watch it 24 7. it's on
demand I I gotta be honest man it is it
is people often ask how do you do this
job watching all the stuff reading all
this stuff every day and I'm like you
know it does get really hard sometimes I
was uh I mentioned that we were hanging
out at the casino because we like to go
there now I started playing Hold'em last
week some played like five times now
it's fun I love that game gotta learn
how to play it though and uh that's
funny anyway the the dealer was like I
hate politics I don't want to talk about
it it's too it's too awful and I'm like
I totally get that because what's what
what this country is devolving into is
our politicians are corrupt everybody
knows it Congress is corrupt everybody
knows it have you guys ever heard that
song Everybody Knows you know who who's
the guy who sang that song Everybody
Hurts is REM and I don't know everybody
everybody knows I am no the people in
the chat are gonna know what I'm talking
about and it's at that line like
everybody knows the fight is fixed the
poor standard Cohen yeah Leonard Cohen
there you go the poor stay poor the rich
uh get rich that's just how it goes
everyone knows that dice were loaded it
was Leonard Cohen and Sharon Robinson
wrote it together every everybody knows
and it's been that way for when was that
song written 1988 1988 yeah yeah man I
was two years old when people were
talking about how the system was
completely broken and I grow up and it's
only gotten worse well it seems like
that it's become more apparent but I
think that we have but let's control the
citizens now than we used to I agree
with that I agree there's an opportunity
for success I I agree there's an
opportunity for the Phoenix to Rise From
the Ashes but I am not someone who just
looks around and says everything seems
worse than it was when I was a kid I'm
someone who decided to start asking
older people and so whenever I would
whenever I go out in the past several
months past year or so like the most
recent thing we went to the Antique shop
there's a guy and he's in his mid-60
season I said is it have you ever seen
it in your life this bad never never in
terms of the violence in terms of the in
terms of the corruption the tribalism
the bifurcation all of these issues the
economy and I'm just like I'm I'm look
I'm 36 in about a month and a week I'm
gonna be 37 and I can tell you that in
my life it seems like things are way
worse even like the economic crisis oh
wait to Me Maybe I was just too young
and I wasn't experiencing it no I wasn't
that bad oh it wasn't that bad unless
you had a lot of money we are with like
the lockdown nothing like with the war
two years forced medication people have
been leave their homes people dying in
the world economic Forum talking about
the great reset I mean this is like dude
we've literally just went from having
people like become millionaires
overnight for selling means mean stunks
basically and you know and now again now
we're sitting up here having these same
people losing all that money and trying
to to re-enter into the work like it's
bad Joe Biden gave like the authority of
the American Military to Vladimir
silence what the hell is going on as our
president in our in our lives like and
he just handed over Carlos to this guy
yeah or not not literally but like just
so much money and tanks and like you do
what you need to do to defend
something
amorphous I want to talk before we move
on too far from this I want to talk
about consent which was part of this
original story I don't know if we will
tap it off but like part of what these
these people were like getting young
kids to come on and this is part of like
social degradation and things like that
trying to get 12 year olds to consent
I'm thinking genetic age and solar age
are different you can have an 85 year
old body that's been around the Sun 85
times because you heal your body so much
it looks like it's 40 years old it feels
it essentially is a 40 year old body but
you've been 85 years so you can see like
just just because you've been on Earth
18 times around the sun doesn't mean
that you're more or less genetically
evolved we might have 12 year olds that
are that are more mature than in 150
years than 25 year olds are today like
we may end up becoming so I can see that
but prepare for that crazy argument to
come out when they argue for for uh
grooming 12 year olds and stuff is that
that's not the same that's literally
what the guy said yeah okay good but the
pedo guy based on logic but it's not
based in reason the other thing is uh
when you get someone to consent under
duress it's not a real form of consent
if they don't understand what they're
consenting to they're not really
consenting legally right so a child well
it's capacity they have no capacity to
consent then you legally cannot you know
sign a contract or that person and if
you have a gun to their head and may say
say you like it I like it see he said he
like no you can't do that legal that's
not a legal admission I'll tell you when
it goes too far when we start doing
informed consent forms or research
studies for Pediatric studies where kids
no longer need a parent Guardian because
up until the age of 18 pediatric studies
and this is you know agreed upon by
everybody ever since the Declaration
helensky and all of these other things
and uh the Belmont reports that kids
have to have a guardian that has
capacity to sign that so when they start
you know conducting research studies and
you know God forbid you know your kid
gets enrolled in a study or something
and they didn't have to have you sign it
that's when you know you've gone too far
have you seen that no no and there you
can't that's ethical violation you can't
conduct research that way but it is
darker I mean at that point yeah that's
when you know I
wonder if that'll be introduced more
gradually you know
you know questionnaires your kids can
feel at school without they're Anonymous
it doesn't matter and then you slowly
ramp it up I mean I think
I think the issue for me with all of
this is like why does your 12 year 12
year old need to know about consent like
are you teaching them about consent
before teaching them about safety right
like they should know by 12 that it's
inappropriate for adults to approach
them and talk about these things right
they're saying the opposite they're
saying exactly like it's weird that
they're like well before anything let's
make sure you understand consent and
they might guys it as safety right when
you're older maybe you'll need to know
this but like really it's it's prepping
it's it's I know we're supposed to say
this but groom it if the kid thinks that
they know and Society is telling them
that they know then what do they know
other than that they know yeah and like
what are kids famous for for being like
I know everything I know better than
anyone ever at all time because that's
just part of growing up right so if
you're like well I've taught them about
content and they say they know and
they're 12 or 13 like it just creeps me
out I don't know the only time that
Kamala Harris has ever said something
that was ever correct was that one video
where she said kids are just really dumb
and they're gonna do dumb things but
then her party now wants them to vote
and now wants them to affirm to Medical
Treatments and you know uh sexual
relations so
I don't know thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time